今日はこちらしてが分です
今日は怒らず言葉の勉強について話しいきたいと思うんですが
やはり英語は一番その勉強しやすい言語ですよ
なぜかというと
勉強のその
内容がですねコンテンツが
もう無限にあるんですよ
それが一つ
それから英語の話せる人がこれネイティブスピーカーでなくてもねぇ
たくさんいるんですよ
だからその
それからもう一つですね大体の児童が
これは日本でやろうが他のその英語でない国でもですねやはり小学校高等学校
営業
ある程度も
触れてますよみんな勉強してますよある程度の知識があります
あまりその
話していけないけれどもそれが全く失せろからスターするんじゃないんですよね
じゃあそれに比べて僕の事情ですね今アラブ語とペルシャ語を勉強してますね
毎日
あの
聞いてます
それは朝ごはんを作る時に行きます
夜食事はって全部6ば再来ゼム
キレイにするんですよなぜ
これを聞いています
その運動する時に聞きます車の上でも聞きます
ん
その
じっと座って聞くようなことができないんですよその残りこれから聞きますというん
じゃあのすぐさん
今選挙医者がなくなるんですよ他のことをやりたいんだけども他のことをやりながら
聴くならいくらでもできます
しかし何を聞くかということ
やラブホテルシローの場合はですね
最初のその4
始まった時にリンクが目にストーリー
繰り返して繰り返して聞きましたある程度の水までまあ
つきました
それからですね今 podcast
政治とか歴史とかそういうものに対する podcast を探してそれを
あラボならアラブの方にターン description とするテキストに作って
もらってるわけですよ
金払って
あのいらー官幣社ごぼうな日なんですよ
ペルシアのキャブの声であると聞いてそしてチャンスキャプションを頼んでやっと
勉強できるんですよなぜかというと聞くだけでわからないんですよ
聞くだけでわからないわかりません火消し聞いたら非常に好奇心が強くなる
なんでしたゲーム半分しかわからなかった3分の1とわからなかった
だから敵と見たい的と見て客とももちろんリンクに取り入れて
単語やフレーズを調べて
それから場合によってもえもう一度聞きますそれを優子通りあれやることによって
だんだんだんだんとわかるようになります
徐々にしかし非常に苦労してるわけですよ
それだけのそのコンテンツ来るためにですねそれに比べて
英語はね
まいくらでもあります
アウディオブいい防具
エリー番組ネイティブ ex
無限にあります
間にありますそれからあの
母国語が英語でない人でもその英語でやはり注意しなければならない人が多いですよ
世界中にある
だから非常に恵まれたら環境
だから皆さん英語を勉強するにはですねそんな十役とかそういう教科書じゃなくて生の
ものを
インターネットで探して
あの
毛雲のとそれに伴ったターンスピリットあるもの
毎日きいて聞くのがですね僕のその言葉の勉強の7割がきくきくきくきく器具が全部の
出発点ですね
聞いたらなんでしたがわからなかった
選んで選んで秘書の単語を調べて場合によってはその
文法について大義があるならなぜどうして
それも調べてまた聞いてそれの繰り返し
そういうことをやるには英語がその英語に対する環境が非常に全部揃ってます
それに比べて僕は
最近勉強してるアラバマ号ペン性が劣る9号杭者がすべてそれ
自分でそのあの苦労してねー
アウディをのようなポジが探してまた誰かにそれをたい泊してもあのむらったり非常に
苦労してるはいいですよ
それに比べて皆さん英語勉強しているならば
恵まれますでもちろんその会社コアロボこのそういう
あのー材料がですね今日加えれば臨機にまた皆にあの使用しますあのアラブ ok 車
道
なるほどですねもちろん人気でたくさん
他の言語でもですねまぁ英軍も含めて
たくさんそういう内容があるんですけれどもやはり
新しいフレッシュなポッドキャストか政治とかそういう間
僕にとって非常に興味深いですからそれをメインに
まあ勉強材料
に使っていますあところで
来月ネオいきます一週間だけ
15日カラーですかね15日から23日まで東京東京横浜
もし誰かその3タップですね
集まってお会いしたいならバーあの教えてください
できるだけそれにあのそれをあれ移住したいと思うんです
でまぁそういうことであのー
これですね場合によってはまあ ipad だとか
ipad とかそれがまあ言葉の勉強のもうすごい
あの武器ですよパワーアプリですよ
で
僕がそのアラブ語ページ番号のために pro
してるそのいろんな工夫してますよねそれに比べて英語を勉強している
新しいが非常にも楽ですよだからそれを二ウムに利用して
生の本当の本物のない朗報
エンジョイしてですね楽しみして a
英語のでボロをさらにあの
あっはーいきましょうはいそういうことでもし日本で開いたら非常に今幸いだと思い
ます者なら